let's talk royals because new details
have emerged about harry and megan's
visit for the queen's platinum jubilee
what went down when the sussexes
reunited with prince charles and how it
went spending time with his grandkids
i've spoken to you sources who have
confirmed that there was a meeting
between
charles camilla megan
harry and their children and that this
was very very lovely for the words used
to describe this i do know that charles
absolutely wants to start healing that
fractured relationship with harry i was
told by a source very close to him that
he will forgive his son for everything
did you make kate cry no the reverse
happened i think it's also worth
pointing out that the people that they
didn't meet with were william and kate
and i think that does signal a bit of a
lack of trust i do know that williams
and kate are very worried that anything
they might say or do with the suffixes
could end up being leaked to the media
right now the duke and duchess have a
combined estimated net worth of 60
million dollars plus a reported 100
million dollar netflix deal a palace
source tells et they are now living with
complete financial independence from the
royal family
but don't expect to see any of these
historic meetings in their upcoming
netflix docu-series these were private
meetings and they weren't to be
documented so i think on this occasion
the netflix cameras probably had to stay
away
[Music]